welcome to this video I'm playing the
15-minute game again against the net
profit hmm yeah okay maybe as Slim is
from the US let's see I could let's play
the night off if he goes for the open
yes he does oh that's a very uncommon
type of Smith more I so now i have
Knight f6 and jam e for Hanks you don't
really have a good move to defend it you
can go Bishop d3 but now we get a Smith
Maura with the bishop on d3 it really
should be on see 40 yet another point
like the Danish gambit and there's a
sling
yeah I don't really I don't really see a
reason not to take it especially because
I have the smooth should i do that
really i mean if i have the ideas to
simply kill this b2b shop yeah yeah okay
i have a week square on d5 that's clear
but two points to point to serve
something
yeah the problem is of in this type of
position that the compensation is very
much insufficient because you don't get
to open the position so quickly my pods
on d6 and e5 really blocked the center
and where exactly is white going to
attack here now he is losing a move
trying to get on f7 but I'm quick enough
with castling check Wow yeah does this I
can just take I mean why not check push
up six runs in two nite g5 okay so hmm
the going to g6 a night each form I
don't really believe that even that ass
dangerous but I'm not sure that I want
to do that
hmm ok I can go to f 8 95 and what then
d 5 Queenie eight he might play a form
ok so i've covered made the only real
yeah continuation is this one and I
don't let no real threat right I wonder
if I should just play after h6 CL takes
on e5 I recapture Knight f3 now there's
no real threat or just knight c6 me yeah
I guess just developing
f ed Eve yeah yeah there is a pin so
there are a couple of self mates
possible look gr8 night x h7 checkmate
the drug GI design of course very very
very silly
yeah what needs to get some more pieces
into the tech with maybe 93 95 but now
came 93 I can you can play Knight d4 but
they will problem is that I'm probably
just playing h6 next move I'd sent the
snide back so I don't really see any
compensation if if he even reads to
return this piece
not taking some time 96 I can take Queen
takes and Queen f7 should be very very
solid defense
now trying to get it to c4 or maybe b-52
c7 also also possible okay let's see
just h6 to send it back I can also
consider Queen g6 by the way also um I
know sorry age 63 h6e just returns to a
three HR yeah it does not really scare
me but maybe I have something something
better kawin up seven then but should be
six can also give this check around see
five okay let's send the night back this
should be should be easiest now at age
three I mean I can even just take to
exchange some some more pieces but he
will go to f3 anyway and now again I
need to get the king over 2h7 this would
be really useful so let's see Bishop map
I cannot really I could play a bit
should be 6 cm the Sun as an idea Queen
takes Bishop c5 check winning the Queen
that's actually a nice move Bishop I and
Queen B 7s rupee a twinning on b2 we are
so understand this is a good move just
gaining a temple night c4 that's not a
five winning another piece
yeah this looks very very good and the
bishop only six also makes sure that I
quickly can go create a king g8 2h7 get
the rukon h8 into the game
yeah probably white needs to I don't
really know where where should go
tweenty one runs into loop the eight
Quincy to jump Quincy to maybe but it's
just a piece if I go Knight g4 okay i'm
running into this cover checks Nyjah for
attending Bishop c5 would be quite nice
actually but okay okay maybe just kingi
ATM SOS planned if 9595 Bishop b5 I've
got an ID form and this is overloaded
III Hanks and dodge or pieces hang this
should should win easily and if night be
five I can consider Knight g4 and Bishop
c5 check
yeah so Nyjah form and then then this
check to activate the Carini aid is also
on this night maybe a maybe I can play
discover to take at some point k sub you
should see 5 now to check to gain this
temple night c7 yeah so probably just
here I am yeah I don't want to play it
too complicated 97 I can just prevent if
there is a ch3 I play 93 entering here
this introduces the Bishop c4 idea I can
also just retreat giving up a five but
93 should be should be okay
yeah Bishop c4 is threatened so probably
probably look Roxy one
yeah the night does not have so many
squares yeah okay look see one is the
only move anyway oops okay so playing on
night g6 okay but I can't first take him
and after Bishop takes I mean I can take
the rook but this is this is even
attacking more more pieces be 5v5 and f1
hang or all his pieces hang not a one
but all other pieces it's a quadruple
attack
yeah that's really not much what that he
can do
Queen to f2 I just have a nice choice
probably night f1 Queen h5 maybe but
i'll just take everyone and it's not
even a check yeah bishop f7 was entirely
incorrect maybe you could have tried
night g5 and disposition the sir and
then f4 not sacrificing immediately this
might still be offering some practical
chances ok with the bishop on yet the
bishop is Sir also not so bad but then
he's gotta check Yo no don't want to
allow that not even allowing the check
okay what the easiest stroke a fade
probably
young term it's attacking that do the
shack with a check so I plan read I
retweet here when you fight this Quincy
forward the check don't don't want that
let's see the subway to to play for
medium
now not really don't don't see any any
quick mates Queen g5 ravine just attack
on g2 this is all protecting each other
Luke g1 rook f1 now this is reasonably
quick he has no real way to protect you
too
threatening cringy to checkmate job
there is no Reed offense to that
what is also hopelessly overloaded here
green be too I can take and play this
cover check winning the Queen probably
that's also made
what always strikes me as odd is that
some moves like this check it took 10
seconds to play this which is obviously
super committal while when you're
hopelessly lost you start to think like
a minute a move that's always a bit bit
strange to me of course it's you yes
you're disappointed by the course of the
game and maybe think about what should I
have done better and so on but still
that's not much point if you are so
hopelessly lost just just resign or play
quicker there is no counter attack or
anything going on here
how much time did you spend on this now
like three minutes okay so how to do
this as quickly as possible
check probably take a 91 nah mean
there's some some quick away even and I
don't see one but the queen is good
enough
yeah beginning is taking ages
yeah yeah sometimes wonder for for stuff
like that if I even should upload
because it simply weird behavior by the
opponent and yeah I don't really know
but that's spent like 30 minutes to to
record it and it also fluids fields a
ways to to just scratch the recording I
invested some time and yeah what can you
do I mean it's a bad decision to make
the fool out of themselves not by a bad
play but by this this kind of stuff why
why do I let the clock run down just
resign play a new game you can you might
you might have some interesting things
to do in a nude new game not to let the
clock run down okay so 15 seconds
white forfeits on time ok so what to
take out of this game not much to be
honest but one thing there is if you
play the Smith Mora which which you can
do it's not not not bad you should
really do it like here the first
possible moment because here after the
capture if we set up this position right
has special c4 and this is a very
important point that the bishop is
actually doing something against the f7
Knight f6 is a typical error which even
happens in Grand Master games i did a
video and that you can if you search on
one of the four fours for maura or Smith
Mora you will you will find the game
when amateur play a bit of Grandmaster
with this so the bishop is much better
on c4 and here in this move order the
problem is that after Knight f6 this is
hanging first and you don't really have
a good way to defend it um yeah Turay
you can you can do like something like
that but this is the move c3 does not
make any sense in the structure so this
and now okay he's giving up another pawn
but if you compare this the bishop is
just much worse here there is no threat
you five is not possible and next move I
might even play Bishop g4 d 6 with a
very comfortable position the move
castles gives up another pawn and here
it's debatable i mean i can even
play just night c65 is not necessarily
possible and it's not necessary but I
wasn't I didn't want to have this kind
of position where he really has two
diagonals towards the king it's probably
not enough compensation but this is very
easy to play you just block this Bishop
it's biting only five and Tim I don't
really don't really see much
compensation it's two points not one
pawn so we went Bishop c4 which i think
is ok and now maybe 95 try that one but
now that I think of it I was thinking
about this and this is not even playing
I'll do to Queen B 6 yeah the bishop on
b2 is really a liability and can you can
also continue this line with a complete
win yeah so then then 95 isn't isn't an
idea even the idea of course was if
there wasn't Queen B 6 cm if I would be
obliged to play move like that you at
least have the F file open but even that
is not particularly dangerous yeah so we
took it on and after that i'm just a
piece of its a matter of some cautious
moves to to secure the win yeah I'm
sorry that that you let the clock run
down at the end but it's nothing that
you can do about it and some it's simply
annoying behavior but you cannot choose
your opponent here at that's a simple
point alright thanks for watching